another key in them coming back and
taking game two was Duncan Robinson's 10
points to start the fourth quarter
Duncan Robinson couldn't get a shot off
before the fourth quarter and then he
come out he gets to go in the fourth
quarter and I mean it proved to be too
much for Denver I noticed Denver do
something that I've seen in the playoffs
before which is going back to the
Cleveland Golden State Warriors finals
days what that was if you remember
Cleveland had Kyle Korver and you give
LeBron James a guy like Kyle Korver he's
going to find him he's going to get him
involved and so what we ended up doing
was we ended up calling the corporate
anytime Kyle Carver came off a pin down
anytime he came off a handoff anytime
Kyle Korver came into any action we just
switched it so if I'm on the big I'm
guarding Tristan Thompson they handed
off to Kyle Korver I'm jumping out
almost like a blitz without the second
guy pursuing and just switching but I'm
like heavy jumping out to Kyle Korver
making Kyle Korver have a panic attack
it took Kyle corporate out of the series